The Washington Post reports this morning
that President Trump is causing historic
turmoil in his administration by
refusing to agree that Russia interfered
in the last election the Post says it
has created a quote situation in which
the personal insecurities of the
president and his refusal to accept what
even many in his administration regard
as objective reality have impaired the
government's response to a national
security threat the paper says the
report is based on interviews with more
than 50 current and former US officials
Washington Post national security
correspondent Greg Miller is one of its
authors and he joins us from Washington
Greg good morning so how exactly is the
president's insecurities affecting our
national security well it's in two ways
right one way is that there isn't
discussion of this issue isn't allowed
at the presidential level
he's never convened an NSC meeting on
what happened in the election last year
officials are scared or worried about
bringing up information new intelligence
about Russia that might upset him so in
that way it happens in that and then and
then there is more sort of active things
that the administration has done it is
opposed additional sanctions against
Russia it has tried to roll back the few
penalties that President Obama imposed
before he left office if you recall one
of the measures that the Obama
administration took was to seize two
Russian compounds in the United States
and in in punishment for the election
interference the Trump administration
spent months this year exploring ways to
return those before was sort of forced
to abandon that plan
yeah the US intelligence on this is
clear that Russia tried to interfere in
our elections and a pillar of our
American democracy and yet as you detail
there does not appear to be any
administration effort to try and roll
back those efforts in the future correct
that's right that's right I mean you
know as we've reported this
administration has created a special
commission to investigate widely
discredited claims of voter fraud in the
last election but there is no such panel
to look at election interference from
abroad including by Russia I mean you
could just concise example after example
after example of ways in which the
administration has tried to deny this
reality
Greg why do you think that it's so hard
for the President of the United States
to accept the findings of the u.s.
intelligence committee you know one of
the really surprising things from it
wasn't sure was in interviews with White
House officials for this story you'll
see the quotes in the story they will
tell you face to face
that it is personal they have used this
as an affront as they des D
legitimization of his huge election win
his what he sees as an historic win so
it's very personal and that's why we
write about how this is what makes this
so strange is that a president's
personal insecurities are affecting how
the government responds to a threat you
said you wrote at one point that the
president wants to think that his
charisma had a lot to do with his win
you also detailed that the presidential
daily briefing is allegedly structured
to avoid upsetting him so how does that
work well a lot of the material among
Russia that has to do with the election
will end up just being in the written
portion of the briefing which many
people we've talked to say he doesn't
pay very close attention to they'll
avoid raising it orally with him or talk
around it or put it at the end of the
briefing after they get through other
subjects I mean it's just one of many
examples of ways they try to work around
this super sensitive issue with the
president all right Greg Miller thanks
so much
extraordinary reporting